madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de cette édition du journal
les pics de pollution par l'ozone ont
été enregistrés dans l'après midi dans
plusieurs régions et départements le
nord le pas de calais l'île de france le
nord ouest et le centre la circulation
de cette fan moi n'arrange rien les
études montrent que cette pollution
vient aussi d'autres pays européens
robert weinberg un explorateur de la
biologie moléculaire c'est lui qui avec
une équipe de chercheurs américains est
parvenu à expliquer la mutation des
cellules saines vers le cancer à très
long terme des traitements toujours plus
performants portrait dans ce journal
la longévité des habitants du gers est
de deux ans supérieure à la moyenne
nationale alimentation taille des villes
moindre pollution autant de facteurs qui
expliquent qu'on vivent plus vieux qu
ailleurs dans ce département
norma aux chorégies d'orange c'est ce
soir sur france 2 l'opéra de bellini a
pour toile de fond l'histoire romaine et
l'occupation de la gaule c'est la
soprano hasmik papilles qui incarne
normale après callas et cabaye depuis
hier certains secteurs de plusieurs
départements dont le pas de calais le
nord le loiret la sarthe et une grande
partie de la région ile de france
subissent une pollution atmosphérique à
l'ozone
celle ci est aggravée par des conditions
météorologiques défavorables
l'arrivée de nuages en région parisienne
a cependant limité dans l'après midi ses
effets pour l'instant les autorités
sanitaires ont conseillé aux personnes
sensibles d'éviter tout effort physique
et les limites de vitesse ont été
abaissées une équipe de scientifiques
réunis par le cnrs météo france airparif
surveillent en région parisienne la
formation de cette pollution
reportage dominique barrouche valérie
lucas au sol bloqués dans leur chassé
croisé des vacances les pollueurs 1000
mètres au dessus de leur tête les
chasseurs de zone ça y est repéré on
voit que la concentration d'ozone a
considérablement augmenté pour atteindre
des niveaux de l'ordre de 240 250 les
pics de pollution qui se poursuivent sur
le sud et l'ouest de l'île de france
depuis quatre jours
voilà ce que traquent les scientifiques
le fokker 27 zigzag sur la région
parisienne
en suivant le vent c'est sur la forêt de
rambouillet après la capitale que se
concentrent l'ozone si la pollution
provient de la ville la végétation
constitue un accélérateur
c'est 90% des hydrocarbures émis dans
l'atmosphère ont une origine naturelle
et donc la végétation et les forêts
produisent une grande partie des
hydrocarbures qui vont par la suite
produire de l'ozone ou à partir paris en
est relativement protégé par une autre
forme de pollution celles des particules
en suspension dans l'air qui filtrent le
soleil dès que l'on va sortir de ce
voile de pollution
la réaction chimique va s'accélérer et
on devrait produire à ce moment-là plus
d'ozone un des résultats les plus
surprenants de l'étude est de découvrir
que la pollution provient en fait
d'allemagne et même de pologne
la masse d'air se déplacent globalement
d'est en ouest et par conséquent l'ozone
va s'accumuler progressivement sur les
régions de l'ouest de l'europe
nous avons appris que pour former
vraiment un gros épisode photochimique
donc par l'ozone
il fallait non seulement de la
production de deux polluants locaux et
mis en région parisienne mais aussi une
production une accumulation plutôt de
polluants sur le continent européen
savoir où se trouve le zone prévoir les
pics de pollution voilà le travail des
chercheurs car la science de l'ozone
on est au b à ba aujourd'hui nous ne
savons pas si la limitation de vitesse a
un effet positif négatif sur les ondes
mieux connaître les mécanismes de
l'ozone permettra de combattre la
pollution
voilà donc cette les conditions de
circulation n'ont pas amélioré cette
pollution
ces conditions de circulation se sont
très largement améliorées en fin d'après
midi
où en sont à l'heure qu'il est les
automobilistes nous retrouvons virginie
fiche et qui se trouve en direct de
l'air de repos de saint rambert d'albon
ou en et en virginie
via philippe comme vous pouvez peut-être
le constater juste derrière moi on
circule tout à fait bien sûr la scène ce
soir de même que sur le réseau
secondaire
les difficultés se sont logiquement
déplacer un peu plus vers le sud aux
abords de marseille en direction de la
côte d'azur et sur l'autoroute a9 entre
nîmes et narbonne alors si l'on voulait
un petit peu dresser un bilan de cette
journée aujourd'hui et on pourrait dire
on fait que ça a été la journée des
surprises car effectivement si dans le
sens des départs la matinée a
effectivement été noir le trafic était
très dense et bien le flux s'est
estompée à partir de 13h jusqu'à se
dissoudre totalement débile 7 heures
alors que je vous rappelle bison futé
prévoyait des perturbations jusqu'aux
alentours de 19 et même 20 heures
l'explication est simple les
automobilistes ont tout simplement
anticipé ils sont partis plus tôt la
nuit dernière
la journée s'est donc logiquement décalé
et puis l'autre surprise c'est le sens
des retours la journée qui était prévu
rouge à cette fois viré complètement
ouvert des ralentissements très très
minces ont été constatés et là encore
l'explication est bien c'est une
anticipation des automobilistes qui ont
étalé leur retour depuis jeudi et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on pouvait dire
sur cette grande journée de chassé
croisé dans la vallée du rhône philippe
merci virginie faites attention à vous
vous donnez l'impression d'être en
pleine chaussée dans cette galère
essentiellement autoroutière certains
avaient pensé avoir une bonne idée
en roulant la nuit dernière mal vu
reportage patrick fandio et m'a dit
diawara
autour d'un four il est 4 heures 45 et
puis donc pour cette journée de chassé
croisé
c'est une pure due aux migrations
nocturne un défilé de lucioles de part
et d'autre de l'autoroute a6 ces
noctambules d'un soir sur la route de
leurs vacances peuvent se moquer d'un
pis on peut être pas si futé que cela ne
leur at on pas promis un samedi noir
pour l'instant seule la nuit et son et
sa robe
plus pour longtemps
devant c'est le bouchon c'est la
conséquence d'un accident qui s'est
produit au km 150 de l'accident qui
implique deux voitures qui se trouvent
encore sur l'éveil à deux blessés légers
sur place les premiers ralentissements
de la soirée il y en aura jusqu'à 20
kilomètres au sud de la bourgogne
ce qui fait pester quelques touristes
hollandais grincheux
les la route est bonne mais la conduite
est bizarre drôle de chauffards ici on
en conviendra ce n'est évidemment pas le
meilleur endroit pour tomber en panne
à supposer qu'il en existe un
vous n'imaginez pas une journée de
galère comme celle là non pas du tout
pas du tout
vous avez invité deux voisins
désolé madame
autour d'un faux les six heures pour ce
week end qui promet d'être chargé sur
l'ensemble des axes autoroutiers
épuisés certains endormi sous la pleine
lune quand d'autres ont choisi le
confort exigu de l'emploi suaire en
attendant de repartir avant ce soir
on espère on espère le pense pas
c'est à mon avis
sur les autoroutes qui mène au grand sud
on a beaucoup à espérer ce matin que
bison futé pour être tous fous les
accidents de la route ont causé le décès
de 124 mille personnes en 1998 dans les
28 pays les plus industrialisés du monde
chiffres de l' ocde l'organisation pour
la coopération et le développement
économique
selon une récente enquête csa pour le
secrétariat d'état au tourisme 4
français sur 10 ne partent jamais en
vacances ou moins d'une fois par an ce
sont bien sûr des raisons pécuniaires
qui explique cette privation un exemple
dans ce reportage de caroline boulet et
valérie lucas un repas pour 300
personnes un goût de vacances pour tous
les habitants du quartier régime comme
la plupart de ses voisins passent l'été
à la maison elle ne travaille pas le
contrat emploi solidarité de son mari
fait vivre leurs trois enfants 4 ans qui
ne sont pas partis en famille
un cas loin d'être isolé dans cet ancien
centre textile où le taux de chômage
avoisine les 35 % les trois plus grosses
entreprises ont licencié massivement les
unes après les autres alors les départs
à la mer ou à la montagne
ce n'est pas tous les ans ça nous manque
en dhr est bien comme les au pouvoir
profiter changer d'air
changez partir un petit peu de neuf
catch est quand même et faire comme les
autres profiter aussi
nous coulons inconscient quand même que
ici parce qu'on on n'a pas de gros
revenus donc
pas aller très actif dans son quartier
regina participer à l'aménagement du
terrain municipal en lieu de sept
tous les quartiers groupe et 59,5 sol ou
tentatives mode est bien loin des rêves
de vacances les enfants voudraient bien
plus david juge l'événement dérisoire
tout juste 1 jeudi un peu différent au
milieu de deux mois dans nuit pourtant
partagé le repas c'est l'occasion de
s'ouvrir aux autres de transformer le
voisin on a mis ça fait quand même
manière vacances on dirait on n'est pas
chez soi des gens dont on est sorti
notre maison c'est important 6 avoir des
contacts quoi de contact avec une autre
personne et nous là sur wii
d'habitude les fêtes de quartier st va
se dire au revoir avant de partir en
vacances ici l avant un ailleurs au
coeur de roubaix
à
le secrétariat d'état à la santé met en
garde contre des lunettes importés de
colombie est conçu pour l'observation de
l'éclipsé solaire du 11 août prochain
le repas cité est insuffisante ces
lunettes sont en vente depuis le début
de la semaine les stocks ont été
consignés mais des ventes ont déjà eu
lieu
agnès garder olivier robert monsieur
bonjour direct de la concurrence a lancé
mme ashton la répression des fraudes le
procès dont un contrôle sur la lune et
les éclipses le contrôle par la société
un vendeur de lunettes des clips ils se
sont multipliés ces dernières semaines
ces lunettes sont conformes et sans
danger elle porte bien la mention cep
conformité européenne mais attention aux
apparences ces lunettes distribué lundi
dernier en france viennent d'être
retirés du marché
et pourtant tout y est le sigle c'est
eux le nom du distributeur est le lieu
de fabrication en l'occurrence la
colombie des signes cette fois-ci
trompeur car ces lunettes sont en
réalité très dangereuse la fenêtre on
aperçoit dans toute la pièce
des éléments qui sont claires
visiblement est très clairement elle ne
protège pas parce que elles sont censées
filtrer le visible infrarouges et
ultraviolets et de laisser passer que 1
cent millième de lumière on ne devrait
rien voir sauf quand on regarde un
halogène par exemple on devrait voir que
le filament de l'halogène risque
d'obstacles d'ivoire de cécité partielle
avec ses lunettes les clips ce pourrait
mal tourner trois cent mille paires ont
déjà été vendus en une semaine dans les
magasins décathlon virgin et dans
certaines pharmacies
il est impérative ce soir de les
retourner aux commerçants l'embargo sur
le boeuf britannique décrétées par
l'union européenne en 1996 a vécu le
boeuf anglais fait donc son retour sur
le marché français à des conditions
draconiennes
les exportations d'animaux vivants sont
encore par exemple interdite
au total 5000 tonnes pourrait être
importé sur une année contre 246 milles
il y a cinq ans des associations de
consommateurs se disent néanmoins
inquiète
mary pierce amitié seule la viande
découpée sera exporté du royaume uni
agira d'animaux âgés de 6 à 30 mois
depuis le début de la crise les
britanniques ont dénombré 181 mille cas
de vache folle contre 60 5 a en france
cette décision politique de la
communauté européenne de lever l'embargo
est assortie de conditions
son début a battu dans des halles des
abattoirs agréés donc c'est très
contraignant et on est loin de voir le
marché français et européen est inondé
de pubs britannique
si les politiques français affichait
aujourd'hui à la foire de montesquieu
volvestre une certaine sérénité
les associations de consommateurs de
leur côté dénoncent la levée de
l'embargo
quant aux scientifiques il estime cette
décision trop précoce est fondée dans la
mesure où cette levée de l'embargo est
effectivement prématurée nous savons
qu'il faut cinq ans en moyenne pour voir
les effets d'une mesure concernant
l'encéphalopathie spongiforme bovine
c'est à dire la durée d'incubation
or des bovins aurait pu être contaminé
par des farines infectés jusqu'en 1996
c'est pourquoi les associations de
consommateurs craignent que les viandes
britannique difficiles à écouler sur les
étalages ne soit vendue au rabais au
restaurant aux maisons de retraite et
aux cantines scolaires
cela ne pourront jamais vérifié
l'origine de la viande qu'ils mangent
un nouveau cas de vache folle a été
détecté dans le puy de dôme c'est le
seizième cas d'encéphalopathie
spongiforme bovine enregistrés en france
depuis le début de l'année et le 65e
depuis 1991
l'homme que notre correspondant aux
états unis a rencontré avait pour
ambition première de devenir rabbin
ce n'est qu'à 18 ans que la passion de
la recherche lui est venue robert
weinberg à la tête d'une équipe
scientifique du massachussetts institute
of technology a réussi à reconstituer la
cancérisation des cellules
à très long terme il se dit persuadé que
les dix premières années du siècle
prochain nous apporterons des
traitements auxquels les cancérologues
du xxème siècle n'ont pas osé rêver à
cambridge près de boston pour france 2
philippe gassot le petit homme à
moustache qui a démonté le mécanisme du
cancer ne porte jamais de blouses
blanches
pour obliger la presse en mal de clichés
ses travaux lui ont apporté la notoriété
pour lui ça n'est pas important elle est
reconnue ne m'a pas de pas grand chose
je ne suis pas plus respecté par mes
enfants ni plus ni moins heureux chez
moi et cela ne rend pas mes expériences
plus positive être ce que lutz et
n'apporte pas beaucoup davantage dans la
vie
celui que tout le monde ici appelle bob
géré son labo avec la volonté affirmée
de laisser à tous ses collaborateurs
la plus grande des libertés la richesse
de son laboratoire de recherche c'est ça
faire venir de grandes pointures attirés
par la réputation du lieu
les chercheurs se sont eux lui c le boss
quand ils passent par le département
recherche
ces pourparlers c'est ça son travail
vérifier les hypothèses confronter les
expériences il ne touche à rien ils
auraient peur de tout placée dit il
heureux dans son métier de chercheur il
puise son énergie dans sa famille sa
mère est née à strasbourg en france
quand tout disparaît dans la vie la
seule chose que vous ayez ce n'est pas
l'argent votre métier ou votre maison
la seule chose que vous laissiez
derrière vous c'est votre famille
sa vraie fierté c'est d'avoir construit
de ses mains sa cabane de vacances et
c'est tout est-ce que vous rêvez du prix
nobel n'ont rêvé du prix nobel
c'est un malade et pourtant ce qu'il a
découvert au cours de ces quinze années
de recherche avec ses collaborateurs est
essentielle il sait maintenant que la
cellule cancéreuse n'a pas un seul
défaut de fonctionnement mis trois
rivières réellement trois choses que
nous devons corriger dans la cellule
atteint un peu comme sur une voiture
fiorelli train défectueux un
accélérateur bloqué au maximum et trop
d'essence dans le réservoir
le travail sur les origines du cancer
découvert ici devrait permettre un
meilleur traitement des patients dans
les années qui viennent
cet espoir ne pourra trouver place dans
les hôpitaux que dans cinq ou
il en va immédiatement quand on parle
des qualités de robert weinberg
il préfère éluder première qualité c'est
le sens de l'humour tout le reste est
sans importance la suite de l'actualité
l'étranger avec le kosovo tony blair le
premier ministre britannique s'est rendu
dans la province serbe pour saluer le
contingent britannique de la kfor la
force multinationale sur place il a été
acclamé tony blair était le plus 20 ans
guerre des occidentaux au moment des
opérations de guerre menée par l'otan
contre la serbie
françois corner venant de sarajevo en
bosnie-herzégovine où il avait assisté
au sommet sur la stabilité des balkans
tony blair en tenue décontractée
effectué hier soir une première visite
éclair à pristina pour y rencontrer le
contingent britannique de la force
internationale de paix il a félicité la
kfor pour avoir rétabli l'ordre dans la
province
après avoir salué les américains tony
blair a passé la nuit en macédoine avant
de revenir ce matin au kosovo en raison
de son attitude inflexible pendant les
bombardements de l'otan
le premier ministre britannique aux
côtés de bernard kouchner nouvel
administrateur de l'onu a été accueilli
en véritable héros à pristina par les
albanais kosovars
ce qui n'a pas empêché de s'adresser à
eux pour condamner de manière allusive
les représailles exercées contre les
serbes
oui non nous savons que la justice doit
être la même pour tous soit leur race
leur religion leur niveau social
couleurs passées fermeté de blair
derrière ce sourire de façade avec
hashim thaçi chef de l'ue checa at il a
demandé de cesser de contester
l'autorité des nations unies
le chef du gouvernement britannique a
aussi appelé ibrahim rugova président
des albanais du kosovo à remplir son
rôle au sein du conseil de transition
que l'onu tente de mettre sur pied la
continuté au maroc dans son discours du
trône fils d'assen de mohamed sy s'est
engagé sans surprise à poursuivre la
politique de son père monarchie
constitutionnelle multipartisme et
libéralisme économique
il a confirmé le socialiste abderrahmane
youssoufi à la tête du gouvernement
par ailleurs le roi a gracié 7 1988
prisonniers de droit commun
la plupart d'entre eux avaient été
condamnés pour des délits
et au trafic de cannabis dont le maroc
qui est le premier exportateur mondial
en algérie cette membre de l'un des
groupes d'autodéfense constitué à
l'initiative des autorités contre les
islamistes ont été tués et trois autres
grièvement blessés par l'explosion d'une
bombe dans la région de djelfa à 270 km
au sud d'alger
toujours selon la presse algérienne
trois autres personnes ont été blessées
jeudi sur une plage d'alger par
l'explosion d'une autre bombe
parmi elles le poseur de l'engin un
adolescent de 14 ans n'a donné au pays
de 170 millions d'habitants morcelé en
centaines mille des affrontements entre
musulmans et chrétiens n'ont pas cessé
depuis le début de l'année ceux ci ont
fait des centaines de morts selon des
bilans officiels et des milliers de
déplacés
le pays est dirigé par le président
habib sy qui a succédé à soir tôt
l'année dernière
bernard lebrun minorité catholique au
coeur du plus grand pays musulman du
monde
armés de tuyaux et de manches de pioche
il chante entre deux assauts sous le
regard fatigué des militaires venus en
renfort de jakarta une semaine que cela
dure dans les rue d'amboise musulmans et
catholiques s'affrontent à l'armé
blanche 34 morts depuis lundi 400 depuis
le début de l'année
hier jakarta a haussé le ton les troupes
ont reçu l'ordre de tirer à vue
4000 kilomètres à l'est des moluques
toujours en indonésie l'île de batam
mêmes scènes d'émeutes
mais cette fois opposant deux ethnies
toutes deux immigrés sur cette île très
touristique grâce à sa proximité avec
singapour
eux ce sont les batak venue de sumatra
il se bat pour la prise de contrôle des
moyens de transports de l'île du cyclo
pousse au minibus
face à eux des îliens de flores venus
des îles de la sonde pour s'implanter à
batam
résultat 13 morts en deux jours et une
île désertée par les touristes
de l'autre côté du détroit de malacca à
sumatra et sa province
hadj et ses habitants ont découvert hier
plusieurs charniers 53 morts
un massacre des hommes uniquement
fusillé par l'armée selon des témoins
depuis 1976 un mouvement fondamentaliste
le gan revendique l'indépendance de la
province combattants les fonctionnaires
javanais venue de jakarta logan veut
programmer un état islamique la
répression militaire est impitoyable son
modèle hadj et l'a trouvée 4000 km à
l'ouest au timor-oriental bien sûr car
aujourd'hui l'ancienne colonie
portugaise indépendante en 1974 puis
envahie par l'armée indonésienne en 1975
a enfin obtenu après 24 années de luttes
son référendum d'autodétermination les
nations unies l'organiserons le 30 août
prochain
un an après sa chute
l'indonésie est à l'image de l'ex
général suharto un pays malade un pays
de 170 millions d'habitants
en manque de démocratie que trente
années de dictature ont conduit vers
l'éclatement en colombie en amérique
latine
un attentat à la voiture piégée a fait
dix morts et 38 blessés à medellin dans
le nord-est du pays l'armée colombienne
accusent les forces armées
révolutionnaires qui auraient riposté à
l'arrestation de plusieurs de leurs
membres
l'attentât intervient alors que des
tractations de paix sont en cours entre
le régime et ses opposants
révolutionnaire en dix ans la guerre
civile en colombie a fait 35 mille morts
à madrid de l' incendie d'une station
électrique a désorganisé une partie de
la ville pendant plus de 12 heures
cinq cent mille personnes ont été
privées d'électricité dans la capitale
espagnole la principale gare routière a
été fermé le sinistre n'a pas fait de
victime
huit pompiers ont cependant été
intoxiquées par les émanations toxiques
une enquête récente a montré que dans le
gers
on vivait deux ans de plus qu'ailleurs
en france 83 ans et trois mois pour les
femmes 76 ans et trois mois pour les
hommes
cette longévité exceptionnelle peut être
certes attribué à l'ail ou au grès de
volaille mais c'est plus globalement un
ensemble de facteurs qui expliquent
cette singularité diego garcia jean
louis normandin
impossible de traverser le gers sans les
croisés ici on les aime beaucoup et si
le bonheur est dans le pré c'est un peu
grâce à eux
dans ces paysages il fait bon vivre et
les gens se désiste heureux d'autant
plus que le gers détient depuis peu la
palme de la longévité
dans ce département on vit deux ans de
plus que la moyenne nationale
et cette nouvelle n'étonne pas grand
monde à commencer par les professionnels
de la restauration
pour eux pas de doute le secret de la
longévité passe par la nourriture
alors le secret de la longévité en
gascogne
c'est sa lane avec ça la graisse de
canard et le matin c'est la première
chose que l'on fait en frottent un
croûton de pain avec de l'ail et avec de
la graisse et on arrive à devenir lé
centenaire centenaire avec un peu d'ail
et pas mal de graisse de canard
ils sont nombreux à partager ce point de
vue dans le sud ouest et comme pour les
conforter
de plus en plus de médecins estiment que
le gras contenus dans les confits pâtés
et cassoulet est du bon gras alors dans
ces conditions pourquoi se priver d'un
gracieux 80 vous avez toujours
actionnaire
en fait ici on deale vieux sans se poser
trop de questions
pour certains lima et qualité de vie
explique cette longévité inhabituel peu
d'industries moins de pollution dans cet
environnement la santé davantage
préservés de plus les villes de taille
moyenne favorisent un mode de vie calme
propice aux échanges
c'est du miel mais parfois jeanne
dominique n'hésite pas à faire les 70 km
qui la séparent du marché à auch
ici aussi l'ambiance et à la
convivialité en partage la vie familiale
davy amical la vie du clocher et je
crois tout ça c'est un apport qui sur le
plan moral d'un nouveau coup la preuve
dans le gers ont fumé au bois peu moins
de cancer du poumon
moins d'accidents de la route là aussi
moins de mortalité alors dans ce sud
ouest réputé pour son bien vivre le
mélange de bon gras et de bonheur
villageois pourraient expliquer ce
record de longévité
les bienfaits de la graisse de canard e
n'explique pas tout on a évoqué
plusieurs fois probablement
l'alimentation du cher les graisses
végétales et graisse de canard le peu de
vin les apports de fruits de légumes
donc une alimentation qui se rapproche
un petit peu d'alimentation mini tehran
elle mais je pense que c'est pas le seul
élément et qu'il ya d'autres facteurs
qui sont impliqués probablement pour
expliquer cet allongement de vie mais la
médaille a son revers
dans le gers faute de naissance la
population diminue régulièrement
laissant les personnes âgées un peu plus
seul chaque jour la mort d'andré
soubiran 89 ans au médecin journaliste
et écrivain la célébrité lui était venue
avec les hommes en blanc livre qu'il
avait écrit en 1947 une peinture
psychologique du monde médical de subir
on retiendra qu'il fut longtemps
chroniqueur à jour de france mais
surtout qu'il a évoqué non sans courage
en 1964 dans le journal d'une femme en
blanc la question de l'avortement
ce qui n'était pas évident à l'époque
nous sommes à la mi temps des vacances
c'est l'heure des bilans partiel le
comité régional de tourisme de la région
provence alpes côte d'azur commence à
parler d'une augmentation de la
fréquentation dans le sud sur la côte
atlantique
on attend une saison au moins
équivalente à celle de l'an dernier
christophe de vallans bras alain
darrigrand bien vers l'avant les coudes
à l'intérieur
dans la famille des vacanciers il ya
d'abord les sportifs petite séance
d'étirements ce matin sur la plage
et puis il ya les adeptes du farniente
les plus nombreux ceux qui attendent
tranquillement la marée et ceux qui
prennent les devants mais à châtelaillon
l'essentiel c'est que tout soit venu
donc notre ville à l'île d'aix donc là
vous pouvez y aller au départ de la
rochelle donc en prenant le bateau avec
un petit tour de fort boyard
ici la saison a plutôt bien commencé
premier indicateur l'office du tourisme
il enregistre une fréquentation
légèrement en hausse par rapport aux
années précédentes juillet 99 a été un
bon mois la première chose c'est la
météo
cette année nous avons une météo
beaucoup plus clémente que l'année
dernière et c'est vraiment le premier
critère ensuite les stations depuis 4 ou
5 ans font de très gros efforts sur la
qualité des prestations des services
et puis angers sentiment également que
les gens sont certainement un peu moins
morose qu'il ya deux ou trois ans - de
morosité ambiante c'est bon pour le
moral des commerçants
deuxième indicateur d'un bon début de
saison le sourire du restaurateur
on sent vraiment que cette année les
gens ont envie de sortir de dépenser
d'aller au resto et nous on est assez
content par rapport à l'an dernier il ya
beaucoup plus de monde
il fait beau il n'ya pas le foot alors
on est complet tous les soirs et c'est
une saison qui s'annonce bien vos débuts
aussi dans les campings de châtelaillon
un bon remplissage
il a fait très bons donc est un
tributaire du temps suis fait beau mais
pour l'instant ils sont là reste à
savoir ce que le mois d'août réserve à
châtelaillon
on surveille déjà la météo à chambley en
meurthe et moselle a lieu jusqu'au 11 ou
la 6e biennale mondial de l'aérostat
sion c'est la deuxième plus grande
concentration de montgolfières après
celle d'al bouquet requis aux etats unis
55 nations sont représentées
fabrice hausse et jean-jacques le garrec
ont suivi marque un aérostier ruche 3500
km en voiture
un périple de cinq jours depuis la
russie mais pour marc tous les efforts
sont possibles dès qu'il s'agit
d'assouvir sa passion
ici il ya des centaines de ballons et
j'étais sûr de trouver des gens du monde
entier aussi fou que moi pour venir
s'éclater
avec sa montgolfière marque s'amuse
depuis sept ans il a appris à connaître
les vents à anticiper les trajectoires
le pilotage du ballon est un jeu mais
aussi un art facile d'aller au mais
beaucoup plus délicat de voguer au ras
du sol
c'est super quand tu es en haut tu vois
absolument tout et quand tu voles bah tu
distinguent chaque herbe et tu peux
attraper les feuilles
tout le monde devrait faire ça au moins
une fois dans sa vie
celle dans sa nacelle le pilote est en
contact permanent avec son co équipier
resté à terre son rôle suivre la
trajectoire du ballon récupéré la
nacelle et pourquoi pas félicité le
pilote pour son atterrissage
leonid le coéquipier de mark est
également son sponsor
il a avancé les soixante dix mille
francs nécessaires au voyage hier hyper
hot et c'est son ami c'est vrai j'ai
payé tous les frais de ce déplacement
mais avant tout je suis aussi un pilote
le matin léonie prendra les commandes
comme des centaines d'aérostiers venus
des cinq continents tous les jours au
lever et au coucher du soleil
leur ballet makira le ciel jusqu'au 11
août le jour 2 les clips il est interdit
de faire peur aux signaux vache très
beau moment musical ce soir sur france 2
à 22h45 relayée en stéréophonie sur
france culture normes à un opéra en deux
actes de bellini le contexte la gaule au
temps de l'occupation romaine norma est
une grande prêtresse qui ne se doutent
pas de l'infidélité de son amant c'est
la soprano hasmik papian qui succède à
maria callas et à montserrat cabaye et
dans le rôle titre
michel mompontet jean-françois hoffman
en passant par les loges
l'histoire pourrait commencer comme une
devinette un jour d'été premier indice
l'histoire se passe dans ce petit
village de gaulle allant 50 avant
jésus-christ deuxième indice de
farouches gaulois vont lutter contre
l'envahisseur romain qui encerclent le
village troisième indice il ya des
filles de chef il ya des druides qui
attendent leur de bouter les centurions
or de gaulle
il ya même un petit chien que l'on
pourrait surnommer idée fixe
il s'agit donc deux ratés il s'agit de
norma le plus célèbre des opéras
italiens dont l'histoire voilà le piège
à espira uderzo et goscinny
est ce que ce petit chien va rappeler en
restons dans les loges c'est la
superproduction de l'été à orange avec
la magie de l'air le plus célèbre de
l'opéra au coeur du théâtre romain de la
ville sous la direction des veline
hôpitaux casta diva
oh
parce qu'il s'agissait là d'une général
l'heure était encore aux ultimes
réglages réglages en plus que se
rassurer c'est celle en vie le désir
l'inquiétude c'est qu'est ce que c'est
le sentiment juste avant ma joie de
sphère musique la joie bons conseils une
joie partagée face à la grandeur
flamboyante du chef-d'oeuvre du pays
compte au thème la normale un énorme à
défier
et de démesure
ça
voilà norma hasmik papian de ce soir à
22h45 spectacle des chorégies d'orange
sur france 2 et sur france musique
c'est la fin de ce journal dont je vous
rappelle le principal titre la pollution
s'installe dans les villes de plusieurs
départements français les conditions
atmosphériques reste défavorable
ce soir la préfecture des yvelines
décide de maintenir la réduction de 20
km/heure de la vitesse maximale
autorisée sur les routes du département
donc dans les yvelines
sachez enfin que sur la route des
vacances les difficultés de circulation
sont en passe de se résorber
complètement ce soir dans un instant au
bulletin météo complet par patrice
drevet 22h45 norma demain midi géopolis
l'équipe emmenée par claude sérillon
s'intéresse à la ville idéale est assez
philosophe et à ses architectes qui ont
planché et qui planchent reportage de
jean jacques dufour et jean-louis melun
fin de cette édition excellente soirée à
tous
sur france 2